if we want to get the upside of owning a
stock while still mitigating the
downside in case the stock price goes
down we saw that we could buy a stock
and an appropriate put option so that
when the stock goes below some price the
put option starts to have value and so
it mitigates our downside and just as a
review these payoff diagrams are the
values of or at least the one on the
left is the value of our holdings at
some future date and we're defining that
date to be the maturity date of the
options under question now and this one
over here is the profit at that maturity
date and that's why we're subtracting
the actual cost to enter the position on
this one on the right now the question i
want to answer in this video is how can
we how can we get the same payoff
diagram without buying either stocks or
puts and as a bit of a clue think about
what happens if we were to just buy a
call option actually let me do it in
that same color so if you were to just
have a call option the payoff diagram
would look like this you would never
exercise the call option at expiration
unless and we're assuming this is at
expiration or at maturity but if the
stock price goes above 50 you would then
exercise your option to buy it at fifty
dollars so then it starts to have value
as the stock price goes above fifty
dollars the stock price goes to sixty
you would exercise your option to buy it
fifty and then you could sell it sixty
and you would make ten dollars so your
stock your you start to get some of the
upside so how can we shift this graph up
to get exactly the same payoff diagram
well we could have a call option
and we could own something that would
have that would essentially shift this
entire graph up by fifty dollars so we
could have essentially a fifty dollar
bond or a bond that is worth let me
write it this way a bond that is worth
bond
that
is
worth
fifty dollars
fifty dollars at option expiration so if
there's some interest we're getting we
might be able to buy it for a little bit
less if there's zero interest then it's
pretty much like cash we would pay fifty
dollars for it but the payoff diagram
for a bond that will be worth fifty
dollars at this date at maturity or at
expiration the payoff diagram for just
the bond would look like this would just
be a straight line it's guaranteed to
pay you fifty dollars so if you own the
bond and the call option below 50
the call option is worthless so you're
just going to have the bond over here
and then above 50 you still have the
bond but now the call option is worth
something so you have the value of the
bond plus the call option so at 60
dollars the call option is worth 10 the
bond's worth 50 the combination is worth
60. and so the combination of the call
option plus the bond you see it here on
the left it's actually going to have the
same payoff diagram of as the stock plus
the put so you have the situation here
that this a stock plus an appropriately
priced put or a put with the appropriate
strike price is going to be the same
thing when it comes to payoff
at at a future date at expiration as a
bond plus a call option and this right
here is called put call parodying it
shows the relationship between all of
these different securities and if any of
the prices start to
kind of
not make this thing hold true there
might be an arbitrage opportunity but
we'll cover that in future videos